so I was at the medium I got
there you know it's it's a real prison
with the doors bam and they can open the
little tray thing and feed you out of
the tray and there's a a stainless steel
toilet and sink and you know they have
that in the county too but you know it's
it's exactly what you think of prison as
being but it feels like a fundamentally
different experience when it's 26 years
and the door locks and yeah so I yeah I
have a
s and but I'm also they sent me to a
prison where guys have tons of guys have
30 40 50 years you know life sentences
there's there's gangsters there there's
uh there's murderers there's serial
killers there's you know really bad guys
uh there's you know there's guys that
are you know trying to take advantage of
guys right you like sexually yeah
um but by the time I got there I'd heard
all the you know how you can get
yourself in trouble you know how you can
like don't go in somebody else's cell
you don't know the guy you're not 100%
sure do not go in his cell don't even go
near his cell don't go into places where
you people can close a door behind you
or they can trap you in an area don't
there's all these things that I've been
told not to do again for sexual reasons
right because I'm I'm a
small guy in prison yeah you know
trative W dude yeah it's a problem it's
a problem
this yeah it's bad it's all bad well
it's good in the outside world but not
bad in Theon you know yeah my fear was
there make me shave my head to make sure
that the mop wig fits correctly but
there's certain things that I always
hate to say this but Ian and it this is
the simplest way to say it is that if
you get stabbed in prison you had it
coming you did something they're not
running around just stabbing people you
did something you and and the things
that get you hurt is you argue over the
TV what channel you want to watch you
got 50 80 guys watching One TV don't
argue about it like it's none of just
not worth it um borrowing things that
and not returning them that's a problem
running up debts that's a big problem
you know
gambling gossiping you know those are
the problem those things get you hurt
not being polite be respectful I'm super
respectful